Das sind wirklich krasse zahlen derzeit leben mehr als siebeneinhalb milliarden menschen auf der erde und
80 millionen menschen kommen pro jahr dazu das sind so viele wie die einwohner deutschlands
und die rasant wachsende weltbevölkerung ist ein problem denn schließlich gibt es nur eine erde und zwar mit begrenzten ressourcen was sind die konsequenzen
was können wir tun das jetzt alles bei klickst du uns in fischen
Vielen dank denen sie und herzlich willkommen und vielen dank an euch für den coolen themenvorschlag auf whatsapp
das ist wirklich wichtiges thema aktuell leben fünfmal mehr menschen auf der erde als im jahr
1900 und dieser trend ist nicht zu stoppen fakt ist oder das zeigen zahlen ein rückgang der kinderzahl kann vor allem durch die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung eines landes gelingt
investitionen in bildung arbeitsplatzschaffung sexualaufklärung
gesundheitsversorgung und gleichberechtigung zwischen mann und frau tun ihr übriges
wenn frauen wirklich die entscheidungsfreiheit haben wie viele kinder sie bekommen wollen sinkt die geburtenrate eine bessere gesundheitsversorgung für alle
sorgt für eine höhere lebenserwartung und mehr menschen sind länger erwerbstätig das ist gut für die wirtschaft und der staat kann mit den höheren einnahmen
den lebensstandard der bevölkerung verbessern das ganze wird oft als
demografische dividende
bezeichnet und es gibt tatsächlich auch beispiele aus der praxis die zeigen dass das
funktionieren kann thailand und südkorea beispielsweise in südkorea hat die regierung eine langfristig vernünftige familien planungs und
gesundheitspolitik betrieben so dass in den 70er jahren die
geburtenrate massiv zurückgegangen ist zudem wurden die südkoreanischen frauen in den arbeitsmarkt
integriert was die wirtschaft des landes enorm verbessert wir leben einfach in komplett veränderten zeiten und wir als zivilisation
müssen darauf reagieren durch die medizin bessere versorgung und so weiter überleben immer mehr menschen die alterspyramide
die haben wir quasi abgeschafft früher starben die menschen einfach in einer fast
gesetzmäßigen regelmäßigkeit durch krankheiten unfälle behinderung und so weiter und so fort
das ist heute einfach nicht mehr der fall zudem lag das durchschnittsalter dadurch aus wie niedriger
alleine dadurch dass wir länger leben gibt es viel mehr menschen auf der erde und wir müssen als
zivilisation sowie südkorea darauf reagieren und von südkorea könnte sich afrika viel abschauen
denn das alles könnte auch dort gelingen doch bisher sind die prognosen für afrika ganz andere die bevölkerung dort wird sich in den nächsten
30 jahren verdoppeln mehr als 40 prozent der menschen dort sind jünger als 15 jahre
zunächst müsste ist die politik dort schaffen die geburtenrate zu denken senken zudem müsste ihnen die junge generation in afrika investiert werden
schulunterricht haben dort die wenigsten kinder die meisten frauen haben keine ausbildung und so gibt es für sie keine alternative
zu ihrer rolle als mutter und hausfrau das haben auch die vereinten nationen erkannt und haben diesen punkt nämlich die gleichberechtigung zwischen den geschlechtern
als eigenes ziel benannt wenn zu dem auch die
gesundheitsdienste verbessert werden merken die familien schnell
dass viel mehr kinder überleben als sie dachten denn das ist doch der punkt es werden so viele kinder geworden weil die eltern immer noch
davon ausgeht dass so viele von ihnen starben schätzungen zufolge dauert es dann wenn sie verstehen
dass mehr überleben etwa zehn jahre bis die menschen von sich aus eine kleinere familiengröße anstrengen und so gibt es schätzungen nach denen das
bevölkerungswachstum und nur ein drittel
zurückgehen würde wenn paare und vor allem frauen das recht hätten frei
über ihre familienplanung zu entscheiden die überbevölkerung
bringt große probleme mit sich in ländern wie afrika bis asien und dem nahen osten
sind die menschen schon jetzt lange nicht mehr ausreichend mit sauberem wasser nahrung
infrastruktur und arbeitsplätzen versorgen wenn noch mehr menschen unter diesen schlimmen bedingungen leben müssen weil auch die zahl der sozialen und politischen
konflikte steigen eine weitere folge der überbevölkerung ist migration der natürlich machen sich menschen die in solchen
chaotischen zuständen leben müssen auf in andere regionen in denen sie sich eine perspektive
auf die große frage die in diesem zusammenhang immer wieder auftaucht wann haben wir das limit der erde erreicht ein
wenig erinnert das ganze jahr an bakterienkolonien
und ihre exponentiell wachsende produktion population in der petrischale sie werden immer größer bis sie durch die neue lösung
begrenzt werden dann sterben die bakterien ab und die populationen bricht zusammen wann also sind die ressourcen der erde für uns menschen
aufgebraucht und droht uns dann dasselbe schicksal auch wenn die studie des österreichischen physiker heinz von foerster
nicht ganz ernst gemeint war hat er den tag des untergangs auf den 13 november 2026
prognostiziert seine studie basierte auf den daten von 960 und war ein mathematisch angelegt doch was dazwischen kam war beispielsweise
die sogenannte grüne revolution und weiterer technologischer fortschritt der jederzeit möglich ist die nahrungsproduktion
wurde durch neue effiziente getreide züchtung und den einsatz von mineraldünger
vervielfältigt der hunger der erde wurde damit nur eingedämmt aber nicht besiegt es ist ein
regionales und kein globales problem und so etwas macht es schwierig die frage zu beantworten
wann das limit der erde wohl erreicht sein wird in deutschland werden mittlerweile ebenfalls immer mehr stimmen laut dass man auf eigene kinder
verzichten sollte stichwort nachhaltigkeit
das motto also nur der mensch der nicht geboren wird ist
nachhaltig doch andererseits ist leben wert von und zwar jedes einzelne an wirklich schwieriger konflikt und so steht einfach außer frage
dass alles dafür getan werden muss dass alle menschen die geboren wurden auch gut leben können und dafür müssen die ressourcen der erde
vor allem erst einmal
gerecht verteilt werden wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollen dann endet mich bei whatsapp dann um geht ihr die
etwas unzuverlässige hamburgs hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und
zwar noch vor allen anderen täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwestern kanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier kriegen aber nicht die
die glocke vergessen die geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken aliens und klimawandel die zerstörung der erde steht bevor bis dann
bleibt